[Music]
back in May of 2018 this homeless guy
named Michael helped out these two old
ladies these Asian women aged 77 and 79
who were attacked by another homeless
guy I saw this [ __ ] wait everybody's
homeless in the story and so there's
this guy that's which is walking up to
these women and I don't know where he
attacks them and so that's when Michael
comes in and saves the day so I'm gonna
show you guys surveillance this was
pretty great 2018
oh it recently has surfeit like his
interview that I'm about to play for you
guys has recently surfaced so a lot of
people are have eyeballs on it now again
how do they know it's 2018 years using
2018 lingo mm-hm yeah he's close oh no
this story was reported but this
interview was from back then okay I
think I resurfaced because you know
right now there's all this like violence
against Asians like from the corona to
just random like you know like the can
guy that's getting attacked in things so
yeah right so I think a lot of things
like this are surface when I saw this I
thought it was new name me too I didn't
know hey 2018 way back when here we go
this is close that
here's a print coming out the stove
he's got to chase to me held them down
some cops
and I saw that she was bleeding as soon
as I came up closer and she was just
like and then I guess they were trying
to tell us to call the police I started
running look pretty soon when I came in
and they were trying to break up the
fight but he kept pressing me he was
gonna kill her kill him
all of us alone
damn that guy just came out and just
yeah I patch in [ __ ] - that means they
[ __ ] him up probably that guy reacted
fast by the way that was like
instantaneous Wow like an instant rescue
he's he's seen it all oh they caught the
other guy - that was harassing the time
collector guy yeah yeah he was an old
man he was like in his like mid-60s or
some what a loser yeah and then they
said that he had a prior incident where
he jacked the cans from that guy really
yeah that was that was it just wasn't
like he's like a bully - yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm still gonna go down the
steep street a man just clicked in his
cans yeah yeah it's not it's recently
and I thought I thought it was a new
video what do you think like have people
been posting this to be like oh my god
there's as another like hey Asian people
are being bullied yeah I mean there's
this new no no that this one is I think
it's to show that there are you know
cases where there are black people
coming out to in helping Asians because
there is a I think there's a low IQ
group of people that think that there's
some type of one way hate that's going
on right right like we can't perpetuate
that kind of [ __ ] black people hate
Asians [ __ ] yeah yeah we're in it
right after that there's been other
incidents like even today there's that
one dude in the bus that was harassing
the Asian guy and he was doing the
Febreze [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah it just so
happened to be like a black guy that's
doing it I actually had to talk about
this in my citizens of Joe Mallya group
because there was racism toward the
black community coming from mainly
Asians and I was like at the end of the
day folks we can't stoop down to that
level of thinking about one group as
ridiculous I'm like majority of every
race they want peace they want community
they want safety they want all these
things you can't let the bully group of
that community be like the
representative yeah because just one go
to work and take your other families and
[ __ ] that's the majority of people in
general and you can't say like oh all
black people hate Asians or whatever
like these aren't average everyday black
people these guys are like
homeless they're crazy they're thugs
they're like not the actual
representatives I think we're the losers
of the community I think most people
know that I hope but but I think like
you said allows you people maybe on
Twitter and stuff for like you know this
means all black people are like this
that's wild and also I feel like they're
like we got to stop the eight we got to
stop the violence against Asians and I'm
like okay look I'm not even denying the
fact that this is happening right but at
the same time you can't make it seem
like it's like a race riot or like some
type of targeted assault from the black
community right yeah
they're looking for it right yeah
they're looking for it that's the thing
I feel like um anybody that didn't like
that anybody that doesn't like Asian
people now didn't like Asian people to
begin with it's not just cuz of
coronavirus you know I'm saying it was
just like they already felt away and
this is just an excuse you know just
like kind of like how all the white
supremacists came out when when they
felt like it was okay to come out you
don't say like if you if you hate
somebody already you're gonna hate
somebody and like I see these videos and
I never once am I like oh man black
people hate Asian people you know like I
felt like these are just a handful of
isolated incidents yeah but when you
identify with the tribe so hard that
you're in your tribe so much yeah and
then you see other people as other
tribes you know I'm saying yeah so it's
like if my whole life is like white [ __ ]
and I'm around white people all the time
and I'm in white land if I think if I
see aegeon people doing something or
black people doing something and I'm
just about white land then I'm like whoa
that's not having a white land you know
saying so there then everybody becomes
enemies through proxy at night because
of actual earned [ __ ] and it's like it's
like these stupid mental shortcuts that
people have right and they they have to
fight against something but in reality
in every single case that we've been
seeing like for example the can
collector guy right he's had nothing but
positive things to say about the
community that he was collecting cans
from and he's like don't let that be a
representative of this culture of this
group or whatever right but there's a
lot of people that are outraged and
upset they're like we got a stop the
black violence against Asians and
whatever and I'm like man if you ever
grew up
in these kinds of neighborhoods you know
it's a shitty neighborhood problem not a
race problem like there are shitty Asian
kids out there that are going out
jumping other races too like I've seen
it firsthand like it's not like this one
group is is just more violent than this
group or just you know it doesn't make
any sense like you did you grow up in a
[ __ ] bubble where you didn't see [ __ ]
like this I think that's what it is yeah
because if you grew up in a [ __ ]
neighborhood
everyone's violent to each other yeah
the same black bullies are beating up
the other black kids the Mexican kids
whatever all the other kids but it's
just the police yeah they're just
bullies in general my mom was in school
in the south during like when they were
integrating the schools and she had like
a big strong black dude like Lily out of
the kindness of his heart escorting her
to each of her classes because it was
scary then between the races like Dave
there was fights breaking out randomly
people throwing chairs down hallways and
down stairs like it was not like just
simple [ __ ]
but with this guy he like my mom was
never like whoa black people like this
because she had a black guy who was
taking care of her she might have had a
fat ass - that's what it is right so
there were there were black kids at her
school who were violent and then there
were white kids at her school that were
violent but the idea that all of them
were violent or all of them were one way
or the other is so stupid yeah and then
you got a bunch of ignorant ass people
feeding into it online yeah I had to
like I had to like unfollow somebody
that retweeted something on to my feet
and I was like oh [ __ ] up my vibe bro
nobody we know nobody all no like I saw
the responses to very sweet I was like I
gotta get this out of my out of my
universe man because I'm like it was
obviously people that had grown up in
like just secluded areas and they were
just ignorant to a lot of [ __ ] you know
I'm saying just feeding into whatever
they read or whatever like headline they
saw like ah get this out of here same
[ __ ] happens with religion too it's like
all the Jews are this or homes are this
yeah exactly it's funny that the people
sometimes that are trying to stop racism
or actually perpetuating it by thinking
the same way
they don't think that what they're doing
isn't the same level hmm and when you
create blanket statements like that
you're really just I don't know man I'm
like I just want to run away from human
being sometimes mm-hmm it's some stupid
ass [ __ ] but I guess the the group
that's trying to spread awareness of the
violence and all that I mean it's it's
good that we're seeing it I guess cuz
you know we need to make sure that we
don't make that those mistakes but then
how people are reacting to it in a way
that's making it worse I don't know I
don't know how to stop that because
people are just [ __ ] dog yeah and
there was someone tagged me in a video
cuz you know of course they always tag
all of us cuz you know we're Asian and
we have an audience and [ __ ] but like
there was one video that that I was
tagged in where it was like Asian couple
gets gets jumped like on a train or
something in Philadelphia and like the
video was so messy I couldn't even see
if the couple was was Asian oh I saw I
saw that one yeah yeah no no there are
two kids that were getting jumping and
the guy was like yeah like huddling or
agent you could see yeah they were like
Chinese kids or something and then I
don't know there's a lot of mixed stuff
like some stuff said that they were it
was like a corona racism thing it was
another thing it was just kids being
bullies whatever right I didn't really
know but I mean there are a lot of news
coming out right now because I think it
all started off with corona racism right
and then there's like a Singaporean kid
out in England that got beat the [ __ ] up
I saw his face yeah yeah because of
coronavirus or whatever there's that
other video of that dude Chinese dude
smoking a cigarette and in the guy pours
water on him that guy is talented did
you see that very foot no he he ran
after him first and then after that guy
got away did he exhale then all the
smoke you know
last year with someone threw water on he
held that [ __ ] the whole time a drag
after they finally and later he caught
him in and he grabbed his foot and like
oh like damn dude and in that headline
wrote Asian man fights back and I was
like I wasn't really fighting back was
it I tried he got the foot and
everything was impressive impressive to
me about that video was like he caught
the guy after he had already put on a
jacket like it was like that the guy
throw the water on him and then come
running around again like what was going
on I don't know man it's a bunch of it's
just so much stuff coming out and it's
really hard to tell like it in the
subway video with the kids getting
jumped I couldn't even tell what was
going on and I feel like a lot of times
um you know like not that racism isn't
happening because the coronavirus but
there's just so much [ __ ] that's like
kind of like bandwagoning and i don't
want to be so quick to hop on and be
like oh man you know and it's sometimes
if we don't back up the narrative of
what's popular it seems like we're not
backing up Asians in general but I'm
never brushing things under the rug I'm
always trying to look at it as like wait
let's be intelligent here should we act
emotionally here should we just take a
step back and see the situation as
independent cases and I think we can
create a lot of damage by saying hey
right now there's a huge attack from
black people on Asians if we said that
with our voice then what we do is we
rally up like a race war yeah and that's
what I'm not trying to do I'm trying to
bring people together so I never see it
as us versus them I see it as hey
America's got a problem
yeah and it's poverty and it's lack of
education and it's lack of money lack of
a lot of [ __ ] creates yeah anger and
aggression among people that feel
forgotten
[Music]